hi everyone welcome back and in this
video i want to discuss something which
is important and something which you
should know especially all of you who
are still in colleges and haven't
figured out what you should do that is
competitive programming versus software
development software development could
be web development data science anything
you want and competitive programming
well we will discuss what this is so i
have divided this video into seven
important sections which i would be
answering which i think probably are the
most common questions as well so i'm
going to start off with these sections
so the first section the first part of
this video would be setting up my
context and setting the context of video
so about me i have been a web developer
for a very long time i have worked with
a lot of technologies in the web
including javascript node.js php mysql
all sorts of databases as well and i'm
still do work i have written a lot of
code for code damn which you see right
now including the videos which are
delivered the cdns the architecture the
hands-on practice which you do i have
worked with a lot of technologies in the
web development side i have used this
knowledge to do freelancing on sites
like fiverr upwork elance i think elance
is what the name was but yeah i have
earned money i have done projects big
and small i have done personal projects
and i'm also running a business around
the same thing now with goddamn on the
dsc and the competitor side i have
medium level of experience i have used
competitive coding i have tried
competitive coding when i was in school
i have won competitions i have been to
second round third round of google code
jam facebook hacker cup i also tried a
bunch of competitive coding things when
i was in college because of my subject
requirements so i have solved problems i
have seen how the competitive world
works and i have also seen how the real
world the real web programming works and
other sorts of programming as well so
let's move ahead and understand what
matters and why should you pick one over
the other or you know what is exactly
suitable for you in this video let's
just go ahead and discuss that all right
part two of the video dsa and
competitive coding i would like to take
this minute or two right here to
separate both of them people often are
confused a lot and probably fight over
wrong questions when somebody is
probably emphasizing more on the dsa
part and other people think it is
competitive coding when i say dsa ds
stands for data structures and
algorithms this is an integral part of
everyday programming as well data
structures and algorithms if you think
about it it is very fundamental arrays
are data structures you know objects
maps are data structures and you would
be using them a lot in your daily code
as well in javascript when you are
creating an object you are technically
creating a data structure when you are
writing something to an array or pushing
something to an array you are
technically working with a data
structure if you are trying to create a
small algorithm which periodically
notifies you if there's a new tweet from
elon musk that is an algorithm so you
need that algorithmic and data
structures knowledge even to work with
very simple programs what people get
caught up on is when people start
confusing this data structure part with
the competitive coding part and they are
very different it's like taking data
structures and algorithms to a next
level problem right it's like talking
about addition and subtraction which is
data structures but doing integration
which is competitive coding so that this
is the level of difference why because
competitive coding questions are framed
in such a way that they are mathematical
questions so first of all you have to
figure out the actual math logic of the
problem and then you have to code it in
a most optimized and constrained way
that you have to use minimum memory
fastest execution time and the best
algorithm possible so what you have to
understand is this this video is not
about data structures versus software
development this is about competitive
coding versus software development
competitive coding is next level hard
and requires a lot of effort and a lot
of practice to master versus software
development which is relatively easier
to begin but also is hard to master and
create something productive and solid
and scalable it would take you months of
practice if not years with software
development as well it's not that easy
all right so this brings me to the third
part of the video which is what exactly
does competitive coding involve all
right like i said before in order to
solve a truly new competitive coding
problem which you have probably never
seen before you absolutely have to have
a lot of clarity on well code first of
all then logic and then also know a lot
of algorithms which are the best for
performing a certain tasks so for
example if i say you
what's the fastest or the best algorithm
to
just sort a list or perform any sort of
common problems like knapsack problem
for example
you would probably as a competitive
coder you would probably have these
answers on your tips right you would
remember these algorithms you would know
which is the most common algorithm used
to crack this problem because what
happens with competitive coding is you
take a very big problem start breaking
it into smaller subset of problems and
you do it as long as you don't reach a
fundamental base where you have to
create the logic yourself or you don't
reach a point where you can use a
pre-existing algorithm which you
remember you have you still might have
to code it right it's not like it's
built into library but you might just
remember it you might just you know not
know how it works maybe you just
remember the code you just write it down
and it gets the job done so you can do
that but in most cases if you're a good
competitive coder you truly understand
how the problem solving and the problem
breakdown logic works and you probably
if you're a good competitive coder you
are an awesome programmer as well
because you can truly think how to break
down a problem into different paths and
then regroup them and create a solution
out of that my experience with
competitive coding and learning about
this is not good primarily because the
way i learn is not through memorizing
these algorithms and making sure that i
know the right algorithm at the right
time because that's what competitive
coding requires competitive coding
literally has competitive the word in it
right so you have to use as much
advantage as you can to yourself and one
of the advantages is just memorizing
these algorithms right which one is used
where i'm just trying to practice this
over and over again if you have
practiced in your 11th or 12th standard
the standard integration questions in
mathematics you would have seen that
there are certain
problems where you have to just remember
once you break down the integration
question into a certain format there is
a specific format you have to follow
there is a specific algorithm you have
to follow in order to solve that
question if you don't follow that you
will be stuck for a very long time and
this is exact analogy which you can
relate with competitive coding as well
there are a few problems where i think
most of the heart problems where you
would have to know a lot of information
prior to before you even start that
question if you don't know that you
probably will never be able to solve
that question in
the given constraints or given time all
right the fourth part is what does
software development involve now this is
easy software development just involves
you building products for the real world
right whether it's a cli tool whether
it's a web application whether it's some
sort of data processing whether it's
mobile application whether it's data
science which is kind of like data
processing but you are doing something
where either some of the users are able
to see what you're doing or you're
trying to analyze the data from the
users themselves right you're not
specifically writing a core algorithm
which needs to be very optimized and
specialized you know in most of the
cases you're not right some cases yes
you do need to write that but in most of
the cases you don't have to you have to
however
work very well
with
systems right so you have to make sure
that your back end can talk to other
server your one computer can talk to
another computer so the software
developer depending on your field i mean
it varies from one fleet to another but
more or less what you have to be good
with is with systems it's not exactly
with code alone it's kind of like with a
lot of things with code with systems
with programs you have to understand how
these systems talk to each other how
computers usually work what is the
protocol you are using
how to create or set up a server like
from scratch how to set up back ends
front ends depending on again what on
your field but it's more like
you are interacting with something which
is actually there instead of just
solving a problem which you do in
competitive coding which is hard which
is a mathematical problem where you have
to only think about an only write code
based on the logic right which you come
up with so software development is more
like you can say real world programming
and competitive coding is competitive
coding which involves a lot of
algorithmic part this brings me to my
next part which is is competitive coding
used in real world and the answer for
this question is a small yes and a big
no
right so what do i mean by that this
means that for the most part you will
never use those level of questions in
competitive coding which you see in
competitive coding in your real world
projects right even if you need to use
those those level of sophisticated
algorithms you probably don't have to
worry about what is going on in that
algorithm either you can get a library
for that
or you can you know just forget about
him after implementing an algorithm
which you know works fine because you
don't necessarily want to dive into a
lot of details but as a programmer your
job is to just make sure that the
projects are working end-to-end and
ensuring the code quality and stuff but
yeah i mean in real world you focus more
on making sure that your code is
maintainable making sure your code is
modular it's clean you you're not
repeating yourself you are making sure
that the systems are working together
systems are redundant stuff like this
you focus more on bigger problems i mean
it could be bigger or smaller depending
on how you see it but instead of just
focusing only on the code aspect you
focus more on these sorts of problems
and the reason i said yes is because if
you have a requirement which requires a
specific algorithm then there is no
replacement then you need a person who
is good with data structures algorithms
and cp competitive coding to do that
part there is no replacement i mean you
can have 10 developers who know
react and one developer who knows
competitive coding and if you want to
create an algorithm which calculates the
shortest route between two parts those
react developers cannot do anything i
mean your use effect hooks and your
u-state and your declarative programming
and your clean code would not help you
to break down a grid-based problem into
smaller parts and you know running a dfs
bfs whatever the algorithms are to
determine the uh shortest path this part
is irreplaceable right this is also kind
of irreplaceable but you get the idea
that this when required is needed right
so this is also important in terms of
that small yes which i said for
competitive coding use in real world all
right this brings me to my next question
which is why then big companies like
google or facebook ask competitive
codings in their interview rounds the
reason they do that in in fact what i
feel the reason is is because they
receive a lot of applications at volume
right they receive maybe thousands or
tens of thousands of applications per
day now the easiest way to filter out is
to say okay if a person can crack this
really hard problem they probably know
or you know they most definitely know
how to think as a problem solver these
companies they already have the majority
of their algorithms and core
infrastructure built right they need
people who can maintain it upgrade it
and basically are more flexible so they
just need to be problem solvers they
don't necessarily need to set up a tech
stack they don't necessarily need to
bring up a product or service online not
at least on the hiring part they pretty
much just need to be problem solvers
right and the best way to do that is to
just give them a question in competitive
coding let's see how they are able to
crack it whether it's a tree graph based
question anything and then hire them
right if they are able to do that now
it is extremely possible if you are
working on let's say chrome dev tools
front end team right if you are applying
for that job it is extremely possible
that you might be the person who is
extremely relevant for that position you
know how to work with the document
object model and javascript and the c
plus plus and the node bridge and all
that stuff you probably might have
contributed to google's chromium project
or anything but you still might get
rejected right because what these
companies try to focus on is they want
they are okay if a few people who are
capable enough do not get in but they're
probably not okay if a few people who
are not capable enough get in right and
the problem with the real world
programming evaluation at least for now
is that it is
easier or rather i should say it is
harder
to evaluate somebody on spot because
there is just so much knowledge so much
things you can do and it's relatively
easier to evaluate on a combinative
coding problem right you just have to
send them one sit with them for five
minutes ten minutes see how they are
thinking and so on i mean now that i
think about it it's technically possible
to do this with real world programming
as well if you're doing for i don't know
like software architecture or you know
just laying out cloud architecture and
just seeing how the other person thinks
but usually with competitive coding
these problems are very well laid out
they are already present so they just
have to reuse them but yeah i mean if
they could they could just put an effort
and replace this whole evaluation thing
to real world programming as well to a
certain extent and i think a lot of
companies are doing that eventually but
yeah this is this is the reason that
most companies most big companies right
now use competitive coding as an
evaluation criteria because they receive
a lot of applications and they need to
filter out a lot of them very quickly
right and the startups and small
companies who use this criteria where
they don't have any specific competitive
coding needs they are just you know bad
companies to be honest you probably
should just not even try to get into
those companies who are small and they
are putting up difficult dsa rounds and
difficult dsa questions they are not
worth it so the final and the most
important question in this video is
should you learn competitive coding or
not to answer this question you have to
try out competitive coding first i tried
it out i hated it i did not use
competitive coding again and i probably
would never i think you
might like it i know a lot of people who
enjoy competitive coding truly enjoy
competitive coding right and there are
there is this third group of people who
do it just for the placements or you
know just for getting a job the third
one is also fine but it's only fine if
you aspire to go into big companies or
for whatever reason i would like still
ask you to evaluate why do you want to
work for fang or any company when you
can pretty much work for smaller
startups which give you equal bit of pay
and you know you work in a much
tighter environment but yeah that's
that's something for another day but
what you have to realize is if you want
to break into these companies which do
require competitive grounds and of
course you would have to learn
competitive programming but don't do it
only for getting jobs in some company
because you can always get job in some
company just based just on basis of your
software development skills as well if
you're somebody who enjoys competitive
coding don't let anyone tell you that
it's bad this good whatever just keep
doing what you do my personal stories i
did not enjoy it your personal story
might be that you enjoy it a lot and
it's fine there is no one right answer
you do what fits to you in general you
will see that people who learn
competitive coding especially in college
days get an advantage in terms of
getting a job or replacement but that is
fake that does not matter in the long
run if you are a good software developer
it does not matter because as a good
developer you would be picked up by
any good funded company any good funded
startup smart medium size company and
you would probably make more if not same
compared to those people who are working
in fang or you know any other company so
the point of this answer or this seventh
question the final one is that you
should do competitive coding only if you
like it and the same goes for software
engineering as well you should only
build software if you like it or you
know you're okay with it and you want to
get a job you know anything like that so
primarily keep your focus on the fact
that competitive coding is not the only
way to get a job number one and number
two it is okay to not like competitive
coding i see a lot of people getting you
know
just pressured by the seniors or anyone
that you have to do competitive coding
if you want to get a job this that
that's not true especially in today's
world especially in today's remote world
you can pretty much get a good job as a
developer without competitive coding
right i hired my first two people
with first-two developers on code damn
asking zero dsa or zero competitive
coding level questions right one of the
questions in codenames interview was to
actually build a playground like
interface which cooldown uses so you can
get the idea of how the companies at
this scale especially when they are very
small higher and i think that's that's
what i will probably continue for
a long long time but yeah that's my
story and you know my views on
competitive coding versus software
engineering do let me know in the
comments what do you think about this
and if you like the video make sure you
like and subscribe forward this video to
somebody who's stuck between the dilemma
of choosing competitive or choosing
software engineering web development
react native anything but yeah that's
pretty much it for this video hopefully
this was valuable to you if it was make
sure you like and subscribe thank you so
much for watching i'm gonna see you in
the next video really soon
[Music]
you